（あと1分!!!）
あと1分？！やばい
ちょっと上に行こう
ガチやん
え、あとやばい、あと1分だ、やばい
大変だ！電池切れてる....
あー、こわっ！
(うっ)
めっちゃいるじゃん
なになになに
いつからいたの？
ありがとうございます
いつからいた？
いつからいたの？
ありがとうございます
なんすか、ありがとうございます
え、なに、ZOZOTOWNじゃん
開けていいんすか
なにやってんすか笑
使いかけ笑
ありがとうございます
やばい、リア充や
え、いつからいたの？
さっき？
めっちゃバリバリ遊戯王やってたんだけど
なにこれ、なにこれ
ありがとうございます
使わせていただこう
ヤベェ、普通に誕生日だ、なんか
あっ！えっ、なにこれ
(それつけておけば、
東京駅にあってもすぐに電話できるの)
めっちゃつかえるやん!!!
次、これでもうじゃあ、財布無くさないってこと？
やった〜
わ〜、なにこれ
けんすけ？
完全に飲む用じゃん
すげー、ありがとう
キュートレモン
ウィルキンソン炭酸
いや〜、本当にみなさんありがとうございます
あっ、本当だ
みますっ
えっ、まじで？！
え、待って
いや待って、もう一枚ある?!
いきますっ
わぁ〜、ガチじゃん！！
ガチャじゃん笑
マジで?!
ありがとうございます！
そう、野郎だけど、
気づいたら結構、誕生日、人来てくれるっていう
ありがとうございまあすうっ
それはマジでやばい
朝の誕生日、6時6分です
帰ろうっ
あ、ポッ拳だ
......おはようございます....
やばい、もう25歳になってから遊戯王しかしてないっ
今は、バンギラスのところに向かってます
みて、ケルベロス
あたかも俺の車っすみたいなの
ワンっ
おはよー
あ〜、ありがとう
ございます
あ〜、ありありあり、
やった、ありがとう
時刻が2月14日の22時30半でございます
もう、25ですよ？！
だって、初めて会ったの20.....
違うわ
19でしょ？！
あれからもう6年は経ってますよ
やばっ
25っていったら、もうなんかさ、
ほんと、人によってはおじさんみたいな人もいるし、
なんかね、こう
あ〜、ヤベェ、いよいよ
来たなって思うんですけど
やば、もうほんと、若くないからね〜
なんか、徹夜とかもね、
本当に身体、普通に体調崩すし
なんかね、もう無理せずね
なるべく体調に気を使いながら、
まあ、ちょっと自分らしく
楽しく、いけたらいいなと思っております
とりあえず、なんか届いているから
開けてみましょう
こわい、こわい、こわい
すげぇ、小さいもん
なにこれ？！
UUUMのチョコレートだ
ありがとうございます
で、これがかあちゃんからもらったやつで、
これがなんか気づいたら、家においてあったやつ
で、これが?!
書類って書いてあります
ハッピーバスデー
アラサー突入ということで、
スキンケア用品を選んでみました
おめでとうございます
マネージャーさんの方からです
ありがとうございます
なにこれ？！
えっ、なになになに
えっ、なんか、すごい、やばい
ファラオだっ！！！
ネフェルティー??
黄金フェイスシート
待って、金箔入ってんじゃん
もったいないね
使うべきタイミングでっ
な〜に〜？！笑
笑笑笑　やめておけよ笑
いやいや、これは25歳の開け方よ笑
スタジャンですね
なんか、よくわかんないんだよね、
今どういう心境か
若くはないんだよね
若くはないのか.......泣
若い?!.....嬉
とっても若い.....?!嬉
よい、25歳の1年にしようと思っております!!!!!!!
本当に、健康に
いろんな方からたくさんのプレゼントをもらいました
本当にありがとうございます
なんですけど、僕自身
僕にもプレゼントを買ってしまったんで笑
それはまた後ほど、
後日、別の動画で出そうと思っております
じゃあ、ボーリングでも行きますかっ!!!!!!!!!!!